What happens when you paste the name of a classic
movie on a bad movie, and call the thing a sequel?
Let’s say the results are less
than stellar in the case of “S.
Darko”. Stick around to see the full
list of lame cinematic follow-ups.
Horror films and psychological thrillers
are gold mines for unnecessary add-ons,
and plenty of franchises — like "Hellraiser"
and "Child's Play," for instance — which
have spawned numerous sequels that
don't add much to the original story.
In many cases, these sequels end up going
direct-to-video — or straight to streaming,
nowadays — which usually indicates that their
quality is substantially lower than the original.
One of the most egregious examples of this is the
direct-to-video sequel to Mary Harron's "American
Psycho," the classic slasher film starring
Christian Bale as serial killer Patrick Bateman.
Released two years after the original,
"American Psycho II: All American Girl"
stars Mila Kunis as a college student who becomes
a murderer during her time studying criminology.
Christian Bale isn't in the film, but
Patrick Bateman does appear — albeit,
played by someone else with his face
never shown. The connection to the
first film is small, but that's because
there was originally no connection at all.
"American Psycho II" began as an original
screenplay called "The Girl Who Wouldn't Die," but
was undeservedly given the "American
Psycho" title late in production in
a transparent bid to capitalize on the
original film's success. It was a cheap
cash grab that definitely resulted in more
than a few disgruntled Blockbuster customers.
"I have to return some videotapes."
"The Blair Witch Project" changed the horror
game when it arrived in the summer of 1999.
One of the earliest examples of the modern
found-footage genre, the story of three film
students lost in the woods was an unprecedented
success that spawned a sequel only a year later.
However, it wasn't originally supposed to
be released — at least not that quickly.
After "The Blair Witch Project" broke the
record for the best budget-to-box-office ratio
in American history, its distributor, Artisan
Entertainment, wasted no time in greenlighting
a second installment. While production
company Haxan Films didn't want to rush it,
Artisan pushed on regardless, choosing to
move forward without the involvement of
either of the original "Blair Witch"
directors. True crime documentarian
Joe Berlinger took the helm, but
even he was dissatisfied with the
final product after studio executives made
sweeping changes to his initial vision.
The final product was "Book of Shadows:
Blair Witch 2," which came and
went with little fanfare or praise.
The "Blair Witch" franchise was rebooted with
another installment in 2016, but the magic of
the first film still has yet to be replicated —
and it's hard to believe that it ever will be.
"The Bourne Identity" kicked off the Bourne
franchise with a bang, telling the exciting,
yet thoughtful story of an amnesiac CIA operative
on a mission to discover his past. While not every
film in the series was universally acclaimed,
the first three were positively received,
bringing in a combined 950 million dollars at
the box office. While "The Bourne Identity"
was an adaptation of the first installment of
Robert Ludlum's bestselling trilogy of novels,
that didn't mean that production on follow-up film
"The Bourne Supremacy" was a forgone conclusion.
Matt Damon, the face of four out of
five of the films in the franchise,
has commented that "The Bourne Identity" was never
made with a trilogy or even a sequel in mind.
According to Damon, expectations were low
due to a number of production problems,
along with the film's release date being
the same as the live-action "Scooby-Doo."
Even though the Mystery Gang brought in
a bit more cash, "The Bourne Identity"
defied expectations and revolutionized
the action genre for years to follow.
Harold Ramis' "Caddyshack," the 1980 comedy about
the workers and members of an elite golf club,
features an all-star cast that
includes Bill Murray and Chevy Chase.
After the picture surpassed expectations and
catapulted Rodney Dangerfield to big-screen
stardom, Warner Bros. requested a sequel…
and things got complicated from there.
Production on "Caddyshack II" was a mess right
from the start. An initially apathetic Ramis only
agreed to the sequel at Dangerfield's request,
but when numerous story ideas and rewrites left
Dangerfield unsatisfied, he and Ramis dropped out
of the project a few months later. Chevy Chase
was the only original cast member who would end up
appearing in the sequel, albeit in a smaller role.
The actors who replaced the original cast, as
well as their new characters, were the final
nails in the coffin for this troubled sequel. With
terrible reviews and dismal box office returns,
"Caddyshack II" is a follow-up that reaffirms
that some ideas should just be one and done.
Brian De Palma's 1976 adaptation of Stephen King's
"Carrie" is nothing less than a horror classic.
The tale of a high school outcast who wreaks
telekinetic havoc on her bullies has not only
been remade for film and television multiple times
over the years, but also inspired a sequel that
was released a whole 23 years after the original.
Set within the same universe as the original film,
"The Rage: Carrie 2" centers around a young
woman named Rachel who has powers similar
to Carrie, and uses them to exact revenge on the
classmates who drove her only friend to suicide.
Much like "American Psycho II," "The Rage:
Carrie 2" started as an original story,
but the powers that be thought that making Rachel
and Carrie related would boost ticket sales.
Despite the return of Amy Irving
as Sue Snell, it didn't work:
"The Rage: Carrie 2" was panned by
critics and failed to make a profit.
Once a studio decides that it wants a
sequel, there isn't much that can stop it
from happening — but it definitely doesn't help
if the people responsible for the original film
want nothing to do with it. One filmmaker who
was particularly uninterested in returning under
studio control was Richard Kelly, the filmmaker
behind the 2001 science fiction coming-of-age
film "Donnie Darko." Although "Donnie Darko"
didn't do well financially on initial release,
it's since gained a cult following thanks to
its enigmatic plot that follows a troubled
high schooler who's seeing visions
of a strange man in a rabbit suit.
"I made a new friend." "Real
or imaginary?" "Imaginary."
In 2009, the sequel "S. Darko" was
released, centering around Donnie's
youngest sister and featuring a similarly
strange plot. According to Kelly, however,
not only did he have no involvement in "S.
Darko," but he's never even seen the film
and has no plans to watch it any time soon.
That's probably for the best, considering that
critics and moviegoers didn't seem to like it
either. Even though he hasn't released a movie
since "The Box" in 2009, Kelly has promised
his own "Darko" follow-up in the future.
William Friedkin's 1973 blockbuster "The Exorcist"
is widely regarded as one of the best horror films
ever made, frightening in a way that few
movies at the time were able to match.
The battle between two priests and the demon
possessing 12-year-old Regan spawned a franchise
that includes several sequels, a television
series, and a reboot trilogy slated for 2023.
William Peter Blatty, the author of the
novel the film is based on, produced the
first film and wrote the script, winning the
Academy Award for Best Adapted Screenplay.
Since "The Exorcist" was one of the biggest
films of the 1970s, Warner Bros. was hungry
for a sequel, but neither Blatty nor Friedkin were
interested in signing on. Regardless, production
on "Exorcist II: The Heretic" eventually
went ahead with a new writer, new producers,
a new director, and the return of Linda Blair's
Regan as a young teenager dealing with the trauma
of the previous film's events. Whereas the first
film elicited scares, the sequel drew anger and
laughter from both critics and moviegoers, failing
to meet financial expectations in the process.
Blatty eventually returned to write and direct
"The Exorcist III," which was released 17 years
after the original and completely ignored the
events of "The Heretic." The threequel got much
better reviews and has many more fans, but it's
still not as universally beloved as the original.
Sequels typically arrive no more than a few years
after the films they're following up. The odds of
success tend to fall the longer it takes, but
a long wait can still end up with a big hit.
That wasn't the case, unfortunately,
for "Gremlins II: The New Batch."
The sequel to 1984's "Gremlins" showed up
in theaters six years after the original,
and despite earning positive reviews,
it had a dismal box office run.
Director Joe Dante didn't want to make
a "Gremlins" sequel when Warner Bros.
originally asked, but he eventually agreed on
the condition that he could have full creative
control. Dante's vision resulted in a film
that saw the Gremlins invade a New York City
skyscraper, featuring several instances of
wildly anarchic meta humor. "The New Batch"
didn't catch on during its initial release,
but it's acquired a cult following over
the years — there's plenty of fans hoping
that they'll live to see a "Gremlins III."
It's one thing to not be interested in a sequel
— it's another to be forced into one thanks to a
contract. That's exactly what happened to Jan
de Bont, director of the runaway bus action
film "Speed." De Bont felt that the story of
"Speed" had reached its natural conclusion,
but the surprise success of the first film meant
he was contractually obligated to make one anyway.
Thus, "Speed 2: Cruise Control" was
born. Replacing the bus with a boat
and Keanu Reeves with Jason Patric, "Speed
2" failed to recapture the excitement of the
original despite featuring the always-entertaining
Willem Dafoe as the main villain. Even though it
featured one of the biggest, most expensive
movie stunts of the 90s, "Cruise Control" is
only talked about nowadays when listing
the worst sequels in cinematic history.
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about your
favorite movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.